cyberpunk 2077's secret editions are
starting to be discovered no man's sky's
newest expansion is out now and more
during cd projekt red's 1.5 patch reveal
stream it was also mentioned that there
would be some new secrets for players to
discover throughout the game including
one that only three developers know
about and a few of them are starting to
surface user rogue taco art on reddit
shared a clip of a cop vs gang shootout
showcasing the new interactions between
the npcs in night city and this is just
the tip of the iceberg as there have
also been videos of full out npc police
chases caught on cam there are also a
few quality of life changes that weren't
listed in the patch notes such as being
able to skip the braindance tutorial new
photo mode poses inspired by anime and
various balance changes that some fans
are saying it makes the game feel more
like an rpg aside from new secrets being
discovered it has been really fun seeing
everyone share the before and after
photos of their characters and seeing
just how much better they look in patch
1.5 i'm sure we're going to see a lot
more discoveries in night city in the
coming weeks but what are some of your
favorite changes in the game so far
no man's sky is a game that has been no
stranger to updates ever since it
initially launched in 2016. this time
around developer hello games has offered
players the sentinel update the update
features even more of what they want to
see with a complete combat overhaul the
ability to have their own drones to take
care of and more
announced alongside its release the
sentinel update is also going to allow
players to have their own mech friend by
letting the xo mek take the form of a
full on robot with the use of an ai core
not only this but the update includes an
overhaul of the weapons system even more
lore and brand new sentinel enemies with
new combat behavior and while the
sentinel update may be the 19th
expansion coming to no man's sky hello
games is nowhere near the end of its
development life cycle sean murray says
the team is continuously thinking of new
content to add and that the list of
things the team is excited about never
gets any shorter nintendo has open
registrations for the nintendo switch
sports online play test also advising
players that they are strictly forbidden
from sharing any footage the online play
test runs this weekend on february 19th
and 20th for a set period of hours each
day and you need to be a subscriber to
nintendo's switch online membership to
get in nintendo clarified that the
online test represents an in-development
version of the game so players might
encounter some unexpected behaviors or
errors while playing additionally save
data from the test does not carry
forward to the full launch in april and
the test will not run on switch light
consoles what's more is nintendo said
those accepted into the test are not
allowed to share any details from their
experiences these restrictions are not
uncommon for pre-release tests but it's
also not always the rule recently sony
announced that everyone in mlb the show
22's tech test can share all the footage
that they want nintendo is holding this
test to make sure certain technical
aspects of the game hold up at launch
players will get to try out online
tennis bowling and more to get into the
nintendo switch sports test visit the
websites linked in the description to
begin the process
it involves signing into your nintendo
account and redeeming a 16-digit code
supplied to you
have you found any other new secrets in
cyberpunk 2077 let me know in the
comments and of course leave a like
subscribe and come back tomorrow for
another episode of gamespot news see you
later
[Music]